I want to continue from where we left off last week and we left off at a point where
Louisa was being allowed to go into a huge battle with demons. Now all the Saints have
to endure this and some of them have been very famous for it like Saint John Mary Vianni,
have you read about him? The Curia Vars, I love his stories. He's one of the few places I've
actually gone to visit. I'm a person who won't go visit in places but I wanted to see the
bed that the Satan actually set on fire and they kept the mattress. He woke up one night and
his mattress was on fire and he looked up and he saw Satan and he just asked just you and he turned
over a minute to sleep. That's somebody who knew how to deal with him and another time he said to
Satan, "You're an awful boar. You don't tell a pride in arrogance they're an awful boar." So Satan
says, "What do you mean?" He says, "You do the same things all the time and Satan says, "Yeah
because they work." It's only people like you who see through the research. So Louisa has to face
into it as well and don't forget she's only a teenager so her terror and fright at the beginning
are perfectly normal. I think some of us who are not teenagers might give an even worse reaction
and then she has to learn how to deal with them and then after that she just dismisses them,
which is really fantastic. So this is her going into the wilderness. Remember Jesus had to go into
the wilderness as well and he had to be tempted by the devil and he had to deal with it and then
afterwards have a very fruitful ministry. Well Jesus is asking Louisa to be a copy of his life
and his passion and death. So now who can tell the change that encouraged in my interior? She says,
"Everything was horror for me. That love which I felt in me before I now saw changed to
atrocious hate." Have you got it? What pain not being able to love him? So Louisa says,
"Instead of the great love that she always felt for the Lord, this atrocious hate expressed itself."
So that's Satan manifesting his presence because he is atrocious hate and you immediately get the
reaction of a saint, which is I felt sorrow in not being able to love the Lord, which is really,
really fantastic. The thought that the Lord who had been so good to me, I was now forced to abhor
and to curse as if you were a cruel enemy tortured my soul. So the enemy has been allowed to express
himself like this. I could not look at him, that is the Lord, even through his images because in
looking at them, in holding rosaries in my hand, in kissing them, I had such rushes of hate and such
strength that doing that and reducing everything to pieces was just the same. So this is a very,
very powerful interference in her being. And somebody not understanding this would say to you,
"All but possessed people behave like that," which is correct because Satan has actually taken over.
But we've been told that the Lord is allowing her to meet Satan at this level because she's
being called to intercede and to make reparation. So she has to know what other people are actually
suffering. She has to know how to deal with it. Sometimes I put up such resistance that my nature
trembled from head to foot. Now this means she put up such resistance to these insinuations that
are coming. Now this is precisely the battle that the Lord asked of her. And that we have to learn
from her that when temptation comes to us, we have to resist. And you have to resist even
unto blood or even unto death. What do you call that young teenage saint lady who died because
she resisted rape? Maria Goretti. She resisted unto death. Okay, that's why she was canonized.
Because she resisted up and including her death. She would allow herself to die rather than give
into sin. "Oh God," she said, "what a most bitter pain. I believe that if in hell there were no
other pains, just the pain of not being able to love God would form the most horrible hell.
Now only somebody who truly loved God could say that." Now there is no love in hell.
Many times the devil would place before me the graces that the Lord had given to me.
Now as a crafting of my imagination, now she's very imaginative. And therefore if you are an
imaginative person, Satan is going to go in that route. If you're an intellectual as distinct from
an unimaginative, he will approach you through thoughts and suggestions and theories and all
that kind of stuff. And he's just as successful. So it would be such a crafting of my imagination
so that I would make a life more free and more comfortable and so on. And as true as they approached
me saying, "Is this the love he had for you? Is this the recompense?" Now this is terribly
important because Satan is actually approaching Louisa in exactly the same way as he approached
Adam and Eve. Did God say he loved you? Well why does he not allow you to eat the fruit of this tree?
Why is he refusing to let you know evil? If you knew evil as well as good, you'd be like God
himself which is of course an absolute fallacy. Knowing evil doesn't improve anybody. But that's
the way he goes at you that God has sort of let you down and he's been very hard on you and he's
been very unfair and all of this kind of thing. The vast majority of people fall for it. So then
they say you belong to us. Now beside that I want you to put John 844. John 844. That's where
Jesus says the devil is a liar. Do not ever believe him. So whatever the devil says to you,
the opposite is the truth. So you belong to us was absolutely untrue. You belong to us,
everything is over for you. There's nothing left for you to hope for. And I felt such rushes of
indignation against the Lord. You see because that's what they want is that you will fight the Lord
and give in to them. And of desperation being cast into my interior that many times if I found
myself with some images in my hands, the power of the imagination with such that I would tear
them apart. And while doing this I would cry and I would kiss the image. You see it's not her.
What she wants to do is kiss an image of the Lord, not tear it up and destroy it. But I don't know
how I was forced to do it. Who can tell the torment of my soul? The demons made feast and
laughed. Some would make noise at one point, some at another they would yell and shout and
they would deafen with screams. Now that's not people who are trying to win friends and influence
people. That's people who want to terrorize beings I should say. They want to terrorize
and want to control you through fear. So one of the things you learn through temptations
is that Satan approaches you through fear. That's his major weapon. And God approaches you through
love because God is love. And the discernment of the between the two is very important. So they
would shout see how you belong to us. There's nothing left but taking you to hell body and soul
which of course the total lie because your body goes into the grave until the final judgment.
And then you will see what will happen to you. Sometimes I felt myself being pulled
now the sentences in my book say now this now that and now the other I knock all the nows out
because it's not English. Sometimes I felt myself being pulled. Sometimes it was my clothes or from
my chair in which I was kneeling. They would move it and they would yell so that I couldn't pray.
Notice that the yelling and the screaming and all that is not mature. It's the behavior of
immature beings. And sometimes the fear was such that thinking I could free myself I would go and
lay down in bed and since these dins occurred mostly at night you see Satan needs darkness
for his cover and God works in light. But even there they would follow me pulling the pillow and
the blankets. That's why I mentioned Saint John Vienna attacked in bed. But beside it would you
put Sam 91 and when you're reading this text Sam 91 and when you're reading this text again
read Sam 91. He who dwells in the shelter of the Most High and to abides in the shade of the Almighty
he will get all this protection from the Lord and the demons won't bring you down. Even a thousand
would fall at your side would you they'll never get. So what I try to tell people is that if I give
you a scripture like that it really tells you how to interpret this text. Not only is there no
contradiction between the scriptures and this one illuminates the other. But when you're under the
hurricane you don't remember Sam 91 she's going to remember that later okay. Now who can tell the
fright and the fear that I felt I myself did not know where I was whether on earth or in hell.
Now before I even go on I have to tell you she has not yet told her parents what's going on
and she's experiencing all hell in her room as a teenager. Can you imagine? Look how brave she is.
The fear that they would really take me away was such that I could no longer close my eyes to sleep.
So there's the fear used as control. Human despots do the same thing they use fear to control whole
nations. I was like one who has a cruel enemy who has sworn to take his life away at any cost and
I believe that this would happen to me as soon as I would close my eyes. Therefore I felt as if
someone was pulling would put something inside of them in such a way that I was forced to keep the
eyes wide open. Now in putting in her the fear of sleep you know that deprivation of sleep produces
depression and depression produces a lot of other negativity leading to despair. So that's why Satan
would be doing that putting enough fear into her that should actually be afraid to sleep. But I want
you to, I want to give you a little, I think they call it a mnemonic for fear, FEOR. If you write down
FEOR, frightful events appearing real, that's FEOR, that's exactly what she's experiencing,
frightful events appearing real. In other words the impression is given to her that this could
actually happen any moment but it's not real. So but you need to know that about fear anyway
that Satan uses fear and he uses your imagination. He'll use your memory about past events or
present events or future events to frighten the hell out of you as we say. But they are never real
and when you come to the the Lord he will tell you rather quickly the only fear you have is fear
itself. And once you deal with fear, perfect love casts out fear. That's what the Bible tells us.
And once perfect love casts out fear, Satan loses his power. And that's why the Lord has
to give us these teachings because it's not just for a Louisa, it's more for the rest of us than
for a Louisa. So as you kept her eyes open when they were to see when they were going to take me away,
who knows whether I might pluck up the strength to oppose what they were doing. I felt my hair
stand on end. That's fear isn't it? One by one over my head and a cold sweat throughout my whole
person. So this experience was far too real for her which penetrated deep into my bones and I felt
my nerves and bones being dislocated one by one wriggling out of fear. That's real torture.
And she is only a teenager. Other times I felt incited to such temptations of desperation and
suicide. Now that is classic Satan. Did Satan tell Jesus to commit suicide? Yes, he did. Throw
yourself in the paraphet of the temple and he would have fallen at least 300 meters onto rocks
below. You don't need that amount of fall onto rocks to actually die. So yes, despair and suicide
are the things. And sometimes finding myself close to the well that is in the garden she's not yet
confined to bed or to a knife I felt drawn to throw myself into it. Now so many young people
have had that temptation and have fallen into it and have actually killed themselves which is very
frightening. I felt drawn to throw myself in or to take the knife and kill myself. The effort I had
to make in order to run away was so great that I felt the pains of death. And while running away
I felt them come after me suggesting to me that it was useless for me to live if I had committed
so many sins. Now this is all imaginative stuff. Satan will tell you your committed
genius sins whether you committed them or not. Why? He's the accuser. He's the accuser of the
brethren but he's also a liar. This person we're dealing with here was so pure and so holy she had
already received, we're only in volume one, she had gone to receive three specific individual
marriages with God which is unheard of. Most of the saints would have experienced one.
And if you've read the writings of John of the Cross he will tell you that reaching union with
God is it. That's the pinnacle. That's the summit. But Louisa had that and two others before she was
23. So you're dealing with a very holy woman and so Satan accusing her of great sins. He's a liar,
John 844. But I also want you to put Hebrews 12, 4 beside it as well. That for the joy that was
put before her she would endure the cross despising the shame of it just like Jesus did. She had to
follow the same root as Jesus. Hebrews 12, 4. So and they said to her that God had abandoned her
because she had not been faithful which of course is total lie. Even more I felt as if I had done
many wicked things which my soul had never in the world committed. You see there's the truth
coming out and one of the wonderful things about this woman is how clear her mind is.
She's very very clear. She knows this is temptation. She knows that this is an accusation. She knows
she never did it. Wounded people would say oh maybe I did. Maybe I did. I just don't know but
maybe I did. And so your woundedness makes you accuse yourself and you become your own accuser
even if it's a lie. It's very sad. And the one who will commit suicide has believed the lie
and will actually destroy their lives. It's very interesting of what's happening here.
Afterwards she will have no difficulty interceding for people committing suicide or people having a
violent death. She'll have no problem interceding for people who are going through grievous torture
or anything. She's been there, done that and got the t-shirt. And once you know exactly what to do
in her intercession. So the Lord will explain to her that he doesn't ever allow you to have
anything without a meaning. If he has allowed something it is extremely important for your life
and whatever ministry has given to you and it's very important for the people that you've to reach
out to as well. So this is all teaching for us. So she never had committed these sins in the world.
Therefore for me there was no more mercy to hope for according to the demons. In the depth of my
soul I felt repeat how can you live as an enemy of God. Now of course that's Satan to say it.
Do you know who that God is to whom you have offended Kirsten haste? She had never cursed God.
She had never hated God. Satan is saying what he does
and he's insinuating it into her trying to make her say I did what you did. Now that's what
people do when they are torturing a human being to try and get them to confess something they never
actually did. And out of sheer distress and to get out of the pressure that they're in a person
can sign a document they should never have signed. Now the communists use that all the time
in Soviet Russia. They made people sign terrible documents against God and against the church
and against everything, which was not their position. It did not represent that person at all.
It's only somebody at a distance from that awful torture. The nazis I think used it as well
would see objectively what was going on. So they were doing Satan's work. Now do you see what I'm
saying? That Louise is getting it directly from Satan but human beings can also do Satan's work.
And induce a person to commit suicide or anything.
So then the demons said to her now that you have lost the God of your soul who will ever again
give you peace. Who will free you from so many enemies? Now they're not saying that they're the
enemies. The pain was such that I did nothing but cry. Don't forget she's a teenager. Sometimes
I would start to pray and I would feel the demons come over me to increase the torment.
That's like a vicious sort of attack of animals coming over you. Now read Psalm 91 because Psalm
91 will experience and some would beat me. Some would prick me. Some would suffocate my throat.
Suffocating your throat is actually quite frequent. So many people and I know names as well.
The demon has tried to choke them particularly if you're proclaiming the word of God or
teaching godly things like this. It's not unusual. And that's him trying to attack.
So I remembered that once while I was praying I felt my feet being pulled from beneath the earth
and the earth open and flames come out and I was sinking into it. The fright and the pain was such
that I felt half dead. So much so that in order to make me recover from that state Jesus Christ
came and consoled me. Now very very seldom does Louisa refer to Jesus Christ in this official way.
It's always my beloved Jesus, my adorable Jesus, my eternal good, my life, my whatever but it's
never Jesus Christ. It's never this official thing. So that tells you how far she felt away from him
in this terrible time. So he came and consoled me. Now he did tell her that if she was on a
knife point he would come and rescue her. He made me understand that it was not true that I had
placed my will to offend him. Now if you're studying divine will you underline my will.
Because I want to explain something there that's actually vital to you. It was not true that I had
placed my will to offend him and that from the most bitter pain I felt I myself would know that
the devil was a liar John 844 and that I should not pay attention to him. Now it's a bit difficult
not to pay attention to someone pulling and dragging and screaming in your ears and
appearing to drag you down into hell. That for now I had to have patience in suffering these
brothers is what Jesus calls them. I find that fascinating. I don't know about you. And then
peace would come. So let me explain my will before we go on. Let me illustrate it and I always
illustrate it on the person on my right regardless of who they are. So supposing this person does
something to irritate me and without thinking I react I did not put my will into it. It's just
a human reaction. But if I say I'm going to give you a piece of my mind I put my will into it.
I asked the difference between in deliberate sin and deliberate sin. Does that make sense?
If you put your will into it it's deliberate. And if you commit deliberate sin you cannot be
in divine will. You have to know that from volume one. Because living in the divine will is not
ordinary sanctity. Ordinary sanctity is before you come into the divine will. The divine will is the
new and divine holiness. So you have to have made quite a lot of progress spiritually before you
really get into this. And the thing that the Lord demands is that you will go to war with yourself.
And that deliberate thing has got to go. Now supposing you're in the divine will, okay you've been living
divine will all day today and you do this thing he will go immediately. Just like that he'll go.
Because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God. It's that simple. Hebrews 12 14.
Of course you can repent and he'll come back. But if there's deliberate sin and if you hold a
deliberate grudge against somebody out the divine will goes he won't die. You just need to know
that this is very serious stuff. And this is one of the reasons why I really like to explain the
early volumes because there the Lord gets us up to speed that to realize that this is a very
serious commitment to God. So that's why I wanted you to underline you didn't put your will into it.
This was something that was done to you. This was not something that you did. It's not something
you wanted. It's not something you wanted to stay in. You would have got out of it if you could.
Your will wasn't in it. So that's very important and we can discuss that later if you want because
it's a very important point in divine will. So Louisa said this would happen from time to time
when I would really come to the extremes and sometimes in order to put me into even more bitter
torments. In other words Jesus would give her a momentary relief and then let her go back into
the din again. Why? Because there was something for her to learn each time. And if there's something
you need to learn the Lord will put you into the circumstances in which you need to learn it.
It's actually that simple. And if you examine the things that you think are sort of failures or
difficult areas or difficult relationships or whatever it is in your life the difficult things
examine them because there was a hurdle that you needed to jump. And when you jump the hurdle the
circumstances will change. If you keep complaining about it and holding a grudge against people and
all the rest of it you haven't even looked at the hurdle let alone jumped it. But there's a lesson
to learn. And if you have to learn that lesson as you're a part in the kingdom of God he won't let
you off with it. Have you ever had an experience and you said I've been here before? Now the
circumstances may not be identical but the lesson is in other words if the lesson is I have to forgive
somebody here we're back again I have to forgive somebody else. So I obviously did do it right the
last time because I have to repeat it. Or real patience is being demanded from me oh I mustn't
have done it right the last time. See what I'm saying? There are hurdles that we have to jump
to actually get to the point because we have to operate the ordinary virtues before the divine
virtues can come into us. So in the act of that comfort the soul would be convinced because before
that light now underline the light, before the light it is impossible for the soul not to learn
the truth. Now God is that light one John one five. And as you go on in these volumes that light will
be identified with the divine will which is the essence of God. So beside that I want you to put
Sam 36 verse 9. Lord in your light we see light. Sam 36 verse 9. Lord in your light we see light.
You need light in this room in order to be able to see the light. If the room was in darkness you
couldn't see light. We actually need light to see light and Jesus comes as the enlightener. So when
you're reading this in the writings of other saints you'll hear the person saying I was enlightened
on that point. That means light was given to me and I could see I could understand. So the term
enlightenment has gone into ordinary everyday language. So before that light it was impossible
for the soul not to learn the truth. So Louisa would then see what the demons were doing and
the false accusations and blah blah blah. But then when I was back in the fight I would find myself
in the same state as before. In other words she's plunged into darkness and you don't see.
Now what's wrong in the world today is that the people have gone into such sin that they've gone
into darkness and they no longer see the truth. They no longer see the light. They no longer perceive
the presence of God. It's a very dangerous place to be in. And so if you want to have a Sam there to
express her struggle it's Sam 42 43. Sam 42 42 43 is a wonderful description of the soul
in real struggle. Then the next paragraph begins with he also tempted me now he is Satan.
Just make sure you put Satan there in case you would think that it was God. God never tempts
anybody. He also tempted me not to receive communion. In other words you're not worthy.
Imagine Satan telling anybody they're not worthy to receive communion. I mean objectively it looks
so ludicrous doesn't it? And persuading me that after I had committed so many sins it was a boldness
to go there and if I dared to not Jesus Christ but the devil would call us the devil who's talking.
Which would have been one of the devils. And would give me so many torments is to make me die.
However obedience would win. Obedience means that the priest said you're to go to communion
doesn't matter what's happening inside of you. And Louisa has been taught very well
that she was to obey the priest whenever she was in turmoil she was to let the priest tell her
what to do and not to think about it. So that's what she means by obedience would win. It's true
that sometimes I suffered mortal pains such that I could hardly recover after communion.
But when the confessor absolutely wanted me to receive it I could not do otherwise.
Now do you know who the confessor is? If you don't know I'll give you the name. His father
Michel de Benedictos. Michel, M-I-C-H-E-L-E and it's D-E and then Benedictos, B-E-N-E-D-I-C-T-U-S.
He was her confessor when she was a child and also from 1884 to 1898.
So we're at that stage here in Volume 1 and after him Father Gennaro D. Gennaro,
it's amazing that a person could be called Joseph Joseph. Do you know what I mean?
Father G-E-N-N-A-R-O. Father Gennaro D-D-I. The other one was D-E. This is D-I-G-E-N-N-A-R-O.
He was her confessor from 1898 to 1922. So Father Michel de Benedictos was her
priest in childhood and from 1884 but from 1898 Father Gennaro D. Gennaro until 1922.
So this Father Gennaro is one of the major influences in her life. So that's the confessor
absolutely that that's him, wanted me to receive it and I couldn't do otherwise.
So I remember that quite a few times I did not receive it. In other words, look the pressure
that's put on to you. I also remember that sometimes while I was praying in the evening,
they would turn off the lamp. Sometimes they would let out such roars as to strike fear. Other times
feeble voices as if they were dying, a pity me, pity me, you know, but who can tell what they would
do? It was impossible. So this hard trial, I want you to put Matthew 4, Luke 4, beside that,
that's the trial of Jesus and the wilderness. So this was hard time in the wilderness as I said.
After this hard trial, though, I don't remember too well, it lasted for three years,
not three days, not three weeks, not three months. It lasted for three years and this is one of
the shocks in volume one when she tells you the length of time that she has a trial. You say,
oh my God, how did she survive? It lasted for three years. However, there were days or weeks of
interval. In other words, if there wasn't time out, she wouldn't have survived. Not that they would
cease completely, but they had begun to mitigate. So put a heading on before your next paragraph,
put the demons to flight. Because she's now going to learn how to really go rid of them.
Put the demons to flight. And I want to give you as a reference the book of Job, chapters one and two.
The book of Job, chapter one and two. Do you remember the book of Job?
In chapter one, you're told that God was having a council meeting. And of course,
don't ask me where he headed. But he was having a council meeting and Satan was in.
Why was Satan able to go in there? Because he's an angelic being and he was having it at the level
of the angelic beings. So God said to Satan, do you see my servant Job? He's absolutely fantastic.
He keeps the law. He loves me. He does this and blah, blah, blah. He loves his neighbor. And Satan
said, of course he loves you. He says, because you've given him a wonderful wife and a wonderful
family and you've given him property and you've given him wealth and you've given him work. Of course,
he'd love you. So Satan is insinuating that nobody would love God for himself alone. So God says to him,
okay, try him out. But you're not to touch his flesh. The wonderful thing about the book of Job
is that you'll learn, this is why I'm doing this before we do the solution here so you can hear
that the teaching is the same. Satan is like a dog on a leash and when he attacks you will
you realize there's a leash. So you can only do what God permits. He can't go any further.
He's not permitted. So God said, don't touch his flesh. So he had these terrible disasters
that happened. His children died and all the rest of it. And Job's response was God has given,
God has taken away, blessed be God. So he gets 100%. And then Satan comes back,
they have another meeting and then God said, I told you, he's a real child of mine. He really
does love me and Satan said, skin for skin. That's that's where Shakespeare got his thing for Shylock.
Yeah, the pound of flesh. Skin for skin, he said, touch his own skin. And you'll see that it'll
curse you to your face because you see the great horror of the ancient world and very particularly
of the Jewish people was leprosy to have this horrible skin disease that nobody could even
think that there was a healing of. And then of course, all the sores come out and then he's
everybody says, you're a sinner and the sins are on your body and you must have lived a hidden,
bad life and blah, blah. So now the temptations are coming through human beings.
And the biggest one comes from his wife because his wife said, you may as well curse God and die
because that that's the ultimate in sin. If you curse God as you die, you know where you're going.
And that's the ultimate. And this time poor Job doesn't find it so easy to respond.
And then the worst of the temptations was that three counselors were sent to him
with all the thinking of the day, the philosophy and the theology. And they wound him up to the
point where he was ready to scream and commit suicide. And it was only one solution. And that
was that God showed himself to Job. Now this is very interesting then that's in chapter 38.
But when God showed himself to Job, he did not answer any of the things that the counselors were
saying. He didn't answer Job's problem at all. He did something that is totally God-like.
He took Job into a contemplation of creation. And he said, Job, where were you when I created
the morning? And where were you when I said to the sea thus far and no further? And he brought
him to see the greatness of God and the utter massiveness of the kingdom of God. And when God
was finished, Job said, I repent and sackcloth and ashes. I am the man who had been speaking about
things that I didn't know about. He never said a word about the three counselors. The three counselors
could actually be dismissed as fluff. It's very interesting. And so the thing that I've only
given you that in a nutshell, in case you didn't remember the story, of course God restores everything
to him at the end of that story. But the thing is that the saints have to go through this process
and they have to learn that Satan will attack you if Satan attacked the Son of God in the wilderness,
he'll attack anybody. And if you're going to work for God and you're not attacked by Satan,
there's something wrong. Because if you're doing something good for God, Satan is going to get in
your way. And you just have to learn how to deal with it. And if you don't learn how to deal with
your retire early, because otherwise you'll do damage. So this is one of the lessons. Now,
if you're not called to public ministry and all of that, you won't get it at the level that the
saints got it. But you'll get it in your own way. You know, you'll get people insinuating, you know,
here's the one who goes to church and she thinks he's holy and everything and blah, blah, blah,
and they'll do it in a way that sort of gets to you as we say. And you have to learn it's the attack.
And I remember some speaker whose name I don't remember saying to us years and years and years
ago, he said, do this testing, testing. And you'll remember, which is supposed to learn and you're
supposed to give the right response. And of course, if you learn and give the right response, Satan
says, Oh, I go to some an easier pray. And that's how you get rid of him. So here's Louisa going to
learn in one easy lesson, how to get rid of the demons. I remember that after one communion,
the Lord taught me what to do in order to put them to flight. Now notice she couldn't do it
by herself. So put beside that John 15 five. Without me, you can do nothing, meaning nothing good.
John 15 five. That is despising them and not bothering about them at all. Now put N B beside
that. Why do I say that? That's the last thing on the planet any of us would think of doing with
Satan, isn't it? And why does he say that? And it's because Satan's being is pride and arrogance.
And the worst thing that pride and arrogance they can't handle is that you will just dismiss them
and consider them as rubbish. Only humble people can take that. But pride and arrogance can't. So
he's good. That is despising them and not bothering about them at all considering as if there were
many ants. Now you're usually afraid of ants unless you've ever been in Africa and then you would be.
So this is written in Italy. So she doesn't know about the military ants that we had to face in
Africa. I felt so much strength being infused in me that I no longer felt that fear of before.
Now notice the strength of the Lord deals with the fear. All you got to do is ask Jesus to help.
And of course, if you ask Blessed Mother to stand between you and the demon, the demon will go.
So I would act in this way. When they made clammers and noise, I would say to them,
it shows that you have nothing to do. And that in order to spend time, you're doing so many silly
things. That's the way the Curie of ours dealt with them. You silly things, you know. Look at
the way you're going on. Go ahead, do them for when you get turtle stop. Now that means that she's
free. And you see she's free now. There's no longer any pressure. There's no longer any listening.
There's no longer anything. Sometimes they would stop. Other times they'd get so angry as to make
greater noise. And I felt them near me. Now that's a big statement. It's not nice to feel those
beings near you making themselves stronger and doing violence to themselves in order to take me away.
Notice doing violence to themselves. You'll discover what that means in a minute.
I felt the horrible stench that goes with Satan and the heat of the fire. It's true that I felt
a certain shiver in my interior and I will now that shiver in her interior allows them to attack
because they recognize it. If I'm facing an angry dog and the dog gets my fear, doesn't the dog get
the courage to attack? Yeah. So it's that little shiver is still the reason why they would attack.
She's got to get to the point where none of that is there. But I would pluck up the courage and say
to them liars that you are, or we pointed that one out a few times. If this were true, you would
have done it from the first day. Now that's a good point, isn't it? They've been threatening her
for three years and they haven't done it. So now she says to them, but you never did it.
Well, since it is false and you have no power over me, oh, boy, she's quoting somebody, isn't she?
Who said you have no power over me? Jesus to pilot. You would have no power over me unless it was
given to you from above. That's exactly Louisa's position. John 1911. That's exactly Louisa's position.
John 1911. You would have no power over me. But that which comes to you from above. That's literally
a quotation. One of the things I love about these writings is that there are plenty of quotations
from Scripture. And as you go on in the volumes, you'll hear Jesus saying, as Paul would say,
he often quotes Paul. It's very interesting. And I was fascinated when I came across the bit
where it said, as Saint Paul said, that was Jesus talking. I thought, well, it's fascinating.
So you would have no power except it was given to you from above. That's John 1911. Go ahead,
keep singing. And then when you're tired, you'll croak. If then they omitted laments and shouts,
I would say to them, what is this? You could not add to your account today. That is, have some souls
being taken away from you that you lament so much, poor ones. They don't feel well. But I too want
to make a lament a little bit now. All she's trying to do is say that she is now absolutely
despising them, which is what she was told to do. That's all. And they can take this and they'll go.
Initially, they can't believe it. They'll think you'll come around to fear again. They need you
feeling their fear, then they're on top. But if you let the fear go, they've no way of getting at you.
And I would begin to pray for sinners. Now she has it. Now she has it. She's broken through.
I would pray for sinners or do acts of reparation, because this will this sends the demons absolutely
scooten. Sometimes I would laugh when they started to do the usual things. And I would say to them,
how can I fear you cowardly species? If you were serious beings, you would not have done so many
silly things. Don't do yourselves feel ashamed. Don't you make fun of yourselves? If then they
tempted me with blasphemies or hatred against God, I would offer him that most bitter pain.
Do you see how she's broken through? To use the trial for God's glory and also for the salvation
of souls. So I wanted to give you up there at the acts of reparation. I wanted to give you one
Peter five, five to nine, one Peter five, five to nine. That is Peter saying that the devil is going
around like a roaring lion trying to destroy you. But if you submit yourself completely to God,
you have the victory. So I would do violence to myself. Now beside that thing that I would
that violence I made to myself in seeing that while the Lord deserved all the love, all the praises,
I was forced to do the opposite in reparation from many who blaspheme against him freely.
Now beside that I wanted with Matthew 11, 12, where Jesus makes an extraordinary statement, he says,
"The kingdom of God suffers violence and the violent take it by force." In other words,
you won't get to heaven on cushions and you won't get to heaven on cruise holidays.
The people who go to heaven and the people who become saints are the ones who have paid a decent
price for it. In other words, you will actually walk the walk and you'll live the virtues and you
will deny yourself and you'll put the ego aside and you'll surrender to God. All of that is doing
called doing violence to yourself. And so if you want to get into the divine will quickly,
you've got to very quickly get into mortifying yourself, going against yourself. Not my will,
but thine be done has got to be the motto, not my will. And the time you say that's when people cross
you. One of the examples I like to give to people in the divine will, it's not a heavy example,
it's a light one, but it happens all the time. And that is, if I go to the supermarket and I
buy a couple of things, the people in front of me have bought a shop. And you think they turn
around, you've only got three or four items and let you ahead of them, not on your life.
You know, and you look at the person behind you, it's bought everything, and you say,
do they live on an island or something? These shops are open all the time, but it's there all
the time. And if I want to cross the road, that's the only point in the day when there's car after
car after car, and it come, and I'd say, it's okay, Lord, I'm not an hurry. But if you say,
I have to cross the road, it's had to be in time for mass, they have to do, oh yeah, Satan will keep
it up and keep the car is coming. Because what he wants is the pressure and that you get into distress.
And so you've got to realize that as you're learning to do the not-by-will, but time,
that lots of things will go against you, and you'll think it's get at Francis Week or
get at Francis Year or whatever, it's not really, it's that you're being exercised,
then after a while it's fine, because you learn that God is never in a hurry and he's always on time.
But some people who are always distressed and head off are never on time, because they spend
all their energy in the head off and distress. And so they haven't actually got time to deal
with the thing that they're supposed to deal with. So we learn how to calm down, live in the here and
now, live in the presence of God, choosing his will, denying mine. That's actually terribly
important, terribly important, because you're not going to get anywhere in divine will if you're not
deliberately choosing God's will against your own. And if somebody is cross or nasty to you or
anything like that, that you do not say I have a problem with that person, that God has given me
the opportunity to be kind, can, and forgiving, that's the issue. And if the person wasn't cross
and nasty with you, you don't have the opportunity to be kind and forgiving and so on. And when you
begin to see what the issue is, it's so much easier. It's so much easier. Because if you say
you're going to choose and live the divine will, he's got to give you an opportunity to choose it.
There's a wonderful story just to illustrate it. At the same time that the Lord was speaking to
Louisa Picaretta. He was also speaking to Maria Valtorta. Italy produced three great saints at the
same time in the 20th century. Pedro Pio in the heel of Italy, Maria Valtorta a little bit further
up and Louisa a little bit further up, all at the same time, they all knew each other. And it is
totally fascinating to see the way the Lord was revealing himself to them. To Maria, he revealed
about 60% of the gospel in absolute detail and explained it to an extraordinary degree.
But in one of the scenes in the gospel, Peter is saying to Jesus, "Look, why don't you give
Judas a week off or somebody's driving us crazy?" And Jesus said to him, "Peter, were you around when
I taught the doctrine about forgiveness?" Yes, Lord. "Did you hear what I actually said?" What did you say?
"I told you you must forgive 70 times the seventh time." Oh dear, sorry Lord. And then Jesus said,
"I forgive you," illustrated the point. And Peter had an absolutely extraordinary sense of humor.
He was the only one who could make even Jesus laugh at terrible points. And he turned around and he said,
"What is 70 by 7? 490, isn't it?" He said, "I 489 more chances."
And then a couple of months later, he said, "He's driving us crazy again. Would you give
him a few days off?" And Jesus just said, "Peter." He said, "Yes, Lord." And Jesus said to Peter,
"If I don't give you the opportunity to forgive 70 times the seventh time, you can't become
a saint in that area. Judas is very good for you," he said. "Do you need a book like that
to give you an insight like that?" And because we're not inclined to think that somebody who is
making us forgive them 70 times the seventh time is actually very good for us. That's not the
conclusion we come to. We come to the conclusion that person ought to get their comeuppance or
they need counseling or they need something or other, but I don't need anything. And Jesus said,
"It's actually quite the opposite." So when you come to this kind of teaching, it's the exact
opposite of what the world is telling you, the exact opposite. So in the early stages,
when we're dealing with volumes one to four, the Lord is giving you an opportunity to make sure
you know you should be living the virtues, that you should be coming close to him,
and that you should be in this battle against yourself. I have to underline that because otherwise
you'll get nowhere in the divine will. You might enjoy the readings, but you won't actually get
anywhere in the kingdom of divine will. So there we are. The kingdom of God suffers violence and
only the valiant or the violent taken by force. So Louisa said, "She has now come to the realization
that you pray for sinners and you make reparation and all the rest of them." So in reparation for
many who blaspheme him freely and who do not even remember that you can't say, "Ah, God exists."
That God exists. "Ah, God is merely a transliteration from Italian." It doesn't work in English.
"Whom they are obliged to love in return. If they incited me to desperation in my interior,
I would say I don't care either about hell or about paradise. What I care about is loving God."
Now many of the saints have given that response. They've even said to Satan,
"It's all right. If you take me to hell, I will love God there." And that would destroy hell, you see.
This is not the time to think about anything else. Rather is the time to love my good God as
much as I can. "Paradise and hell. I place in his hand. He is so good who will give me what is best
for me and will give me a place in which I can glorify him even more." Isn't that a fantastic
freedom? Look at the freedom she gets and the insights. Now that's one of the reasons why the
Lord will let you go through a trial that you've got to grow in wisdom. You've got to grow in
insights and understanding about the mystery of life and the mystery of salvation and so on.
So we're now going to get a very important teaching on how to be freed from all this stuff.
Jesus Christ, notice the formality again. And that formality is because of the terrible trial
she's been through. It taught me that the most effective means for the soul to be freed from
every vain apprehension, whether it comes from yourself or anybody else or Satan. To be freed of
every doubt, to be freed of every fear, was to protest before heaven, earth, and hell that you
do not want to offend God. Now the next time you find yourself in temptation, try that out and
you'll snap out of it. "I want to love God. I declare it before heaven, earth, and hell.
And myself, I want to love God. I do not want to sin. And what you've done is you've used your will.
You've made a very assertive statement and the demons will cry off because they know they're
up against a strong will, so they will go." The soul declares that she does not want to offend
God even at the cost of her life and that she does not want to consent to any temptation of the devil.
Now the way the church has traditionally dealt with that is twice a year we have this "do you
reject Satan? I do. Do you reject all his pumps and all his promise, false promises? I do."
And so the church is getting us to say, "I do. I do not want anything to do with Satan."
Actually it's a very good thing to repeat every now and then for yourself because it's the
positive use of the will declaring who you are and who you want to be.
And Louisa says, "As soon as the soul feels the coming of the temptation, in the act of battle,
that is in the temptation itself, if she can, and as she begins to feel free and also during
the course of the day, in other words, until the storm passes, you keep on pushing the clouds away."
By doing this, the soul will not waste time in thinking about whether she's consented or not
because the mere memory of her promise will always give her peace.
And if the devil tries to disturb her, she will be able to answer that if she had the
intention of offending God, she would not have protested the opposite. So in this way she would
remain free of any concern. Now I want to go back to something that the soul would not waste time
in thinking about whether she consented or not. If a person goes to confession and says, "Father,
I was tempted to blah, blah, blah, and I don't know whether I sinned or not." That's not confession.
Confession is for sin. And the priest can't give you absolution for a sin you did not admit to.
Because if you see, "I don't know whether I did or I didn't," then he has no matter for confession.
And yet people make that mistake quite frequently. It's because they're afraid to say,
"I hurt her and I wanted to do it as well." Now if I tell the priest, "I hurt her and I wanted
to do it as well." Because of Sutton, the priest can help me. He knows he has a sinner that needs to
repent. And so all the gifts that he was given in his ordination will come out and will help me
to get free of this wanting to get revenge. Does that make sense? But if I say, "I got a temptation
and I don't know whether I gave in or I didn't," he has no matter for confession. It's a very
frequent mistake. And Satan will want you to go down that route because you've never really confessed
and therefore you can't get absolution for something you didn't confess. I hope I'm not
disturbing the hell out of you. The whole idea is to free you. So the next little paragraph,
she gets the victory. Now who can tell the rage of the devil? Because by acting in this way,
all of his tricks resolved into confusion for himself. That's your 1 Peter 5, 5 to 9 again.
1 Peter 5, 5 to 9. It's also James 4 verse 7
and Revelation 2, 3. You get the crown of victory once you have fought the battle.
And where the devil thought he would gain, he would actually lose and his very temptations
and tricks were used by the soul in order to make acts of reparation for God. Will the devil
continue if you turn his temptations into reparation and acts of love for God? He will not because
that's the exact opposite of what he wants. He wants you to despair and no longer love God and no
longer hope in God and commit suicide hopefully and be his forever. So it's the most wonderful
victory there. The other way that the Lord taught me to cast away temptations was the following.
If they tempted me to suicide, I was to answer you have no permission from God. Why is that?
A Satan don't forget is a creature. What is the no permission? It's the fifth commandment
thou shalt not kill. You can't kill yourself and you can't kill anybody else. Poor Ireland.
On the contrary to your annoyance I want to live so as to be able to love my God more which is the
exact opposite of what Satan wants. If then they beat me and they hit me I was to humiliate myself
kneel and thank God because this was happening as a penance for my sins. So the demons wanted her
to give up despair commit suicide and said that the Lord says repent thank God for the humiliation
and offer it in reparation for your sins. Satan won't come back. It's the exact opposite of what he wants.
And not only this but to offer everything as acts of reparation for all the offenses against God
that were made in the world. Now when she moves on a bit into divine will because this is only at
the beginning this will happen at a divine level so it will affect all souls past present and future
which is really incredible. But I'll deal with that when we get there. See what the Lord does
is he takes a step by step and what human beings want is to skip a whole lot of steps. I remember
the very first seminar I ever held in this house with Tony Hickey and talking to us about divine will
after a couple of hours he said does anybody got a question and of course it was too new a
brandy was to ask a question and then one person put the hand up they said is there a short cut?
We all wrote laughing a short cut from 36 volumes and from trying to grow in divine holiness. I mean
the only decent thing was to do is to laugh and that's what cured the speaker was the short cut.
The Lord takes a step by step or as he says himself drop by drop because we can only learn
in small doses. I mean if you got two months dinner put in front of you today
would you manage it? No but if you got it every single day the right portion for two months would
you take it? Yeah would your body benefit by taking two months food today? No you'd probably die.
But if you take the right portion every single day for two months your body thrives. That's why
you get it piece by piece and there's no short cut. Lastly an ugly temptation that lasted for a
short time was that after being in contact with demon so ugly for about a year and a half
I would become pregnant and deliver a little demon with horns. That's very very interesting
you're dealing with a teenager. You're dealing with an age in which sex education wasn't thrown
in your face and sex wasn't thrown in your face morning noon and night and she knows enough to know
that Genesis 6 said that demons the fallen ones the Nephilim had sex with human women and actually
produced children so it's not an absolutely unreasonable thing that is coming to her head but
it's an awful thing to tempt a little innocent teenager with and that's that's that's the demon
being nasty. My imagination would you see she's a very powerful imagination and the poor girl was
working on this full time. My imagination would breed itself in such a way that I saw myself in
a horrible confusion in the face of what people would say about because of such an awful event
which couldn't happen to her she had fought the demons a hundred percent but look at the way they
play on your imagination and that's why we have to be careful of things we actually look at
because there are lots of stuff on the internet and on television and everything that is very
much playing into Satan's hands and if you let it play on your imagination you're brought trouble
on yourself. Finally after about one and a half years of this fight the cruelties of the demons
ceased and a whole new life began that's the bit you underlined. They were trying to tell her
everything was over and done and finished and she could give up and she could commit suicide
and end up in hell and instead of that this was simply a trial that she was to go through
and a whole new life was going to come out of it. Although the demons did not stop bothering me
from time to time however it was not so frequent the battle was not so fierce and I became used to
despising them. So that's like saying storms continued outside but you begin to realize it's
winter storms come but I'm not going to have a crisis every time we have a storm. So the next
paragraph is the new life begins and this is the beginning of her great visions and her visitations
from the Lord. Then you realize that that whole trial she went through was all preparation for this.
The new life that began was at the farm called Tori Disparata. That is a farm belonging to her
uncle and aunt that she stayed in for a while but eventually they brought her home because her life
was too strange for them. One day while more than ever I was tormented by the devil to the point
that I felt I was losing my strength knock out the s if you have it. I was losing my strength and
fainting around evening while I was in this state I felt that I was having a deadly fit and I lost
consciousness. Now this is her first ecstasy. Louisa will never admit that she had ecstasy and
she had it every day. Ecstasy means that you have been pulled out into God's presence and you're not
available to anything around you so if somebody touches you you're not going to feel it so to people
outside of you you're unconscious. Louisa is so humble she will never ever use the word ecstasy.
She won't even use the expression out of the body experience and she's going to have them on a daily
basis. She just says I lost consciousness or I was drowsy or whatever. She used various expressions
but she'll never ever say the word ecstasy. She'll never use a big word like that. I felt I was having
a deadly fit and I lost consciousness. At that in that state I saw Jesus Christ. Now notice it's still
formal because I mean she's been with demons for a long time surrounded by many enemies.
Some were beating him. Some were slapping him. Some were driving thorns into his head. Some were
breaking his leg. Some his arms. After they reduced him almost to pieces they put him in the arms
of the Madonna. That's not her usual way of referring to our blessed mother either. She always calls her
"Mama". But if you've been three and a half years dealing with demons you're not going to be familiar
with God for some time. Even though she's in ecstasy it's fascinating how it actually affects you.
And this happened not too far from me. After the most holy version, that's much more like it.
After the most holy version took him in her arms she drew near me and crying. She said to me,
"Daughter". She how my son is treated by men. Now she calls us "Daughter" because she was made the
mother of the church and the mother of humanity at the foot of the cross. I think that's John 1926.
I think it's either 26 or 27. I think it's 26. Daughters she said, "See how my son is treated by men".
The horrible offenses they commit which never give him any respite. Look at him how he suffers.
Now blessed mother is going to be very much involved in bringing Louisa close to Jesus and keeping
her close to him and keeping her on track in her mission as well. And if she ever is tempted to
pull back, blessed mother will push her forward because her interest is that all the rest of her
children will be saved. So Louisa said, "I tried to look at him but I saw all blood and all wounds
and almost cut off reduced to a mortal state. I felt such pains. We would say I felt so terrible
that I would have wanted to die a thousand times rather than see my Lord suffer so much. I felt
ashamed of my little sufferings". Now this is her being introduced to her vocation as a victim soul.
The most holy virgin added but always crying, "Come closer to kiss the wounds of my son".
He chooses you as we would say, "Ah, victim", and you'd have to put the word "soul". And you'd have to,
you'd have to do that because at the time we're living in the word "victim" has a very different
meaning. So you have to put in the words "victim soul" and then we understand what's being said.
So our blessed mother is the one who introduces her to her mission. And if many offend him by
offering yourself to suffer what he suffers, notice the life has to be identical, you will give him
a relief. Now you will learn eventually that a relief means that souls will be saved,
that souls will be snatched out of Satan's grasp. You will give him a relief in so much
suffering, won't you accept? Who was it that offered the vocation to Mactimilian Colby?
It was the best mother as well. She said, "Luisa said I felt so annihilated,
really overcome. I saw myself so bad." Now in the original Italian, she uses the word "cativa"
for "bad". It has the meaning in English of "you're not a little thing". In other words,
by comparison of what God is doing and who God is and the grace is given to me, I'm terrible,
you know, I'm not worthy. So she uses this word "bad" all the time. But if somebody came
reading this from a worldly point of view, they'd say, "But this woman is a terrible person." She
even admits it herself. So they would be completely misrepresenting her. That's why in the early
volumes, most people actually need someone to guide them through it, just so that they actually
interpret it correctly. Then when you get to the higher volumes, you're fine. So Luisa said,
"I felt myself so bad and I still am, and unworthy that I didn't dare to say yes. My nature trembled."
That means the human body trembled before the idea of suffering, because suffering is not
natural to us. "I felt so weak from the past pains that it barely left me a thread of life."
Then I don't know, I saw demons yelling and shouting from afar. Now notice they're
afar now, they're not close. Why are they not close? Because she's an ecstasy and there's Jesus
and Mary there. So they have to be afar. And I saw that everything that I had seen the Lord
suffer, they were going to do to me if I accepted. So she says, "I now see the function of these
so-and-so's that if I have to suffer, they're going to give it to me." So if you and I have to
suffer in our everyday life, somebody has to give it to you. And we're inclined to criticize and
condemn the somebody instead of saying, "Oh, that person is God's chosen instrument."
We don't usually give that reaction to it. I felt such pains, suffering, pulling of nerves
within me, pulling of nerves would say our nerves were completely taught, that I thought I was going
to leave life. Finally, I drew near and kissed his wounds. Now this woman is nothing if she is
in completely brave. She's described all her feelings of revulsion against suffering and
blah, blah, blah being attacked by demons. And at the same time, she loved Jesus enough to go
forward and kiss his wounds. So in spite of her feelings, she tries to respond. And she's most
brave. She's wonderful. It seems that after I did that, those limbs so lacerated would heal.
And the Lord, who before seemed to be almost dead, would begin to revive again.
So the Lord now shows her the power of her intercession as a victim soul if she will go forward.
That it will actually make a difference to him. Now when she sees him in suffering, of course,
it's the body of Christ that she's looking at because Christ is in glory. So it's the body of
Christ is looking at in glory. So it's going to make a huge difference to the church and the world
if she will actually do this. Interiorally, I received great lights. So he gave her great
understanding about the offenses that were given and the attractions to accept being
being a victim. So she actually recognized the attraction of grace.
So the amazing thing about her is she could describe that her body would react negatively
and yet her soul would give a different response. Most of us haven't got that kind of discernment.
Though I should suffer a thousand deaths for the Lord deserved everything and I could not
oppose what he wanted. This happened while we were in mute silence. I'm going to finish this
paragraph otherwise it won't make sense and then we'll stop. But those gazes that we exchanged
were so many invitations. Now here you have the eyes are the windows of the soul and here you have
the Lord inviting her with his eyes and Louisa responding with hers. So there you have the
response of two lovers. The song of songs is all over volume one. We'll get to it more and more.
And it pierce my heart through the most holy virgin especially spurred me to accept
because she's the mother of all the redeemed so she wants them all out. But who can tell what
I went through? Finally looking at me my book says benignly we would say kindly the Lord told me
you've seen how much they offend me and how many walk along the paths of evil and without
realizing it fall into the abyss. Now that's Matthew 714 there are two ways and the ones who are going
on the broad way are going to hell. Matthew 714. So come to offer yourself before divine justice.
St. Therese, you offered yourself to divine mercy. Come and offer yourself before divine
justice. That means the ferocious amount of suffering coming as victim of reparation for
the offenses that are given and for the conversion of sinners who with eyes closed drink at the poisoned
fount of sin. What marvelous language that is. A large field of sufferings opens up before you
yes but also of graces. I will never leave you again put beside that Joshua 1 5.
I will never leave you or deserve to. I will never leave you again. I will come within you
to suffer all that men do. In other words Jesus will live his life again in a human being.
Making you share my pains for help and comfort I will give you my mother. A wonderful relationship
with blessed mother and he seemed to deliver me to her and she accepted me. I too offered all of
myself to him and to the virgin ready to do what they wanted. Isn't that fantastic? This is how
it ended the first time and therefore we'll stop there for today but it was terribly important to
let you see the other side of the coin. One side was the trial and the other was the triumph.